I wonder what dominic grieve thinks
about that former Attorney General hello
to you Mr B thanks for joining us on the
program this morning what should happen
to Mr Johnson
well Mr Johnson's explanations have got
to be considered uh by the committee uh
and they've got to do that in an
impartial way and I'm quite sure they're
capable of doing it they're a
cross-party committee and they've got to
consider whether in fact the statements
he made to the House of Commons uh were
untrue Mr Johnson certainly does appear
to have a considerable problem he
attended some of the Gatherings which
were parties and yet he said that there
weren't any Gatherings and it's a bit
difficult therefore to understand how he
didn't know that there had been parties
going on at number 10 Downing Street he
says their work events well the
photograph You're just showing rather
shows for itself uh the nature of the
Gatherings which were taking place they
don't look like work events so Mr
Johnson's got a lot of explaining to do
and of course that is against the
background of somebody who has a Serial
uh reputation for telling untruths
whenever it suits him
well he says that he has a 50-page
written document that he's going to
submit today
um his lawyers have been working with
him and he will be able to prove that he
did not mislead Parliament is there a
difference between misleading Parliament
and an intention to mislead Parliament
it's possible for a minister or indeed a
member of the House of Commons to
inadvertently mislead Parliament and if
you do that you should correct the
inadvertent uh mistake you made at the
earliest opportunity it has been quite
notable with Mr Johnson that he and his
ministers have often this led Parliament
on other matters and never corrected the
record but this is a particularly
serious matter because it went right to
the heart of his government but yes it
is possible that the committee could
conclude that although he misled the
House of Commons he didn't do it on
purpose and that he was himself of the
view that um there weren't parties
taking place at number 10 Downing Street
that as I say the photographs make will
seem to me to demand some explanation as
to how he could make those assertions
when he was both attending events of the
kind that you've uh you can see in the
photographs and on top of that there are
some internal emails in which uh he
States this is the most most unsocially
distanced Gathering that has taken place
so it on the face of it he seems to have
known that there were Gatherings which
were taking place which appear to have
been in breach of the lockdown rules
um you are no fan of Boris Johnson it
has to be said you've said he wasn't he
wasn't suitable to be uh prime minister
and that he was taking the country down
a dangerous path um a lot of your
colleagues don't necessarily agree he is
still incredibly popular with the
conservative party and the growing view
is that it would take um somebody of his
character to try to lead the
conservatives uh going forward if you
lose the next election
well well I'm afraid that just shows the
elements of the conservative party are
still delusional about Mr Johnson and if
they want to continue along that that
path it's a matter for them but Mr
Johnson is not going to help the
conservative party's electoral fortunes
as for uh his future I have no idea the
the committee has got to act impartially
and as Parliament is not subject to any
higher authority because we have this
thing called parliamentary sovereignty
and there's a privilege of parliament so
no court can investigate what goes on
there it is self-regulating so Mr
Johnson I'm afraid can't complain about
the facts that it is going to be a group
of MPS who are going to consider the
material on Wednesday and listen to what
he has to say and they will have to do
their best to set aside all personal
prejudices and just look rationally at
what Mr Johnson says when he says that
he didn't mislead Parliament and look at
the evidence and they've got to come to
a fair conclusion now I'm quite sure
that they're capable of doing that
you mentioned the Privileges committee
the chairman recused to himself step
back because he had previously
criticized the then prime minister Chris
Bryant of course it is majority uh
conservative for three of those who are
on the committee
I want to ask you about Sue gray if I
may and the fact that she was apparently
advising the committee while she was
speaking to the opposition about a new
post working for securma
um perception is not good there is a
I think that Sue gray made I think
difficult to say an error let's to take
it two ways is it wrong for a former
civil servant to go and work for a
political party no it is not and do I
think that Sue gray is as a consequence
of doing a shift in some way tainted in
her approach to being a civil servant in
the years before and I have to say
having known her for many years uh when
she's been a civil servant over the last
10 years or more I'm absolutely
satisfied about her impartiality and
Independence on every subject so from
that point of view the shift
um that she has decided to make to
becoming here starman's chief of staff
is one which in my view is perfectly
acceptable the timing one has to say did
come across as rather unfortunate in all
the circumstances but that's that's a
matter of presentation I don't happen to
think that Sue gray is in any way biased
all that her bias uh but it was present
at all when she was a civil servant in
Downing Street in Whiteville I
understand that
um Mr grieve perception is reality and
she was she put together a report which
eventually brought down the then prime
minister she was advising a committee
which is looking into the actions of the
then prime minister
um and is at the same time talking to
the opposition
but she did her time she did her report
I'm not aware that at that stage she was
talking to Kia stammer about becoming
his chief of staff at pool no but she
didn't there's any evidence of that
whatsoever but she was when she was
talking to the committee well she may
have been when she was talking to the
committee but she wasn't when she did
her report and ultimately it's her
report which certainly uh helped bring
the Prime Minister down but you only
have to look at the content of the
report to see it would be very difficult
for the report to say anything else
because it was backed up by a huge
amount of evidence
quick thought before I let you go on the
situation as far as the Home Secretary
is concerned and raw Rwanda what do you
see happening she says that she'll be
sending people to Rwanda by these summer
I shall wait with interest to see how
many people actually get sent to Rwanda
by the Home Secretary I think it's a
policy which is fraught with difficulty
and uh it will be interesting to see
whether this policy actually works or
not
it's always great to see you thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you
foreign